If none of your current efforts have
worked, you need to do something that
you would never do on your own. You need
to do something so uncomfortable. Yes.
>> Because your current tactics haven't
worked.
>> Yes.
>> Right. And so I'll encourage founders to
be like, "What's something that seems
way too radical or scary that you never
would have thought trying before?
This is permission. Why don't you try
it?"
This is Dalton plus Michael and today
we're going to talk about zombie
startups. Dalton, tell me what is a
zombie startup?
>> Okay. Yeah. So, this is another one of
those where we're going to kind of use
our own internal lingo that we've been
using for a long time and maybe it'll
it'll resonate with the world, maybe it
won't. So, a zombie startup is a startup
that is not dead.
>> Nope.
>> Um like it's there's money in the bank,
like they're making payroll, they have
revenue, they have customers, um
>> but it's not really growing
>> not growing quickly.
>> It might be growing a little bit, but
it's not growing fast. And so it's not
living per se. It's in a interesting
state between living and dying. Yeah.
>> Um, hence the name zombie. Usually the
mentality of a zombie startup is
different than a super fast growing one
where there's kind of like low energy.
There's sort of just like going through
the motions. Nothing that exciting is
happening and it's always like it's like
you're waiting for something to happen.
There's a lot of stalling.
>> Yeah.
>> For some event, external event to
happen. I also think one of the things
that characterizes zombie startups after
a while is like the creep of bureaucracy
and planning and the kind of big company
think
>> y
>> and the slowing down of of dev cycles.
It's almost like the metabolism of the
company is slowing down. It's like the
cell is aging. It's less efficient. It's
like
>> when you have PMF and you're growing
really fast, your job is just to hold
on. Yes. And you're like, "Oh, this is
cha." Every day is like a firefight and
you're just trying to make it.
>> Yes.
>> When you're not growing that fast,
>> what will often happen is process seeps
in.
>> Yes.
>> And everyone's like, "Oh, it's time for
our quarterly planning meeting." And
like like suddenly it'll be get
>> Yes.
>> There is no chaos. There is no
excitement and parts of the company that
are more processoriented tend to take
over.
>> Yes.
>> Um and so it can feel
really slow. Well, and and arguably the
planning is the thing that's exciting.
>> Yeah.
>> Like the product's not that exciting.
The user growth is not that exciting.
>> The planning becomes the thing that's
exciting.
>> So, you know, when there's in the state,
it would be remiss for us to not talk
about like should a company in the state
shut down and what does it mean to shut
down?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think to speak to that,
um, you know, every time you start a
startup, there's only a a few things
that can happen, which is you shut it
down,
>> which is you shut down,
>> you get acquired, or you IPO.
>> Yep.
>> Isn't that weird? There's only three
doors you ever really can go down.
>> And let's not talk like those doors are
like equal in terms of frequency.
>> How many people go through the IPO door?
We know, you know, it's not a lot.
Acquired, okay, it's it's a decent
amount. And then shut down is is up
there. Um and I think a lot of folks
shut down is the expected outcome. It's
up there. It's up there.
>> You're in the top three. Michael
top three.
>> I don't know where it ranks, but uh
>> look, people don't talk about it a lot.
Again, this is not the most engaging
content of this, but like let's because
I haven't seen much content about
shutting down, let's just talk about it
for a second. Yeah.
>> Um what does that actually mean? So I
think that um the most common two
emotions that I see amongst founders.
The first is the kind of personal
failure emotion but I'd actually but I'd
argue that like by the time I'm talking
to them they've kind of processed that.
The second set of emotion are their
obligations to others and that really
grinds on founders. Like I made an
obligation to my employees. Yep.
>> And I made an obligation to my investors
and I've let them down. And the most
common thing that I say is um in that
situation is one like did you act
ethically? Yep. Did you work hard? Did
you lie to people? It's like did you run
the experiment that you tried to run?
And like if the box is checked on all
those four like you fulfilled your
obligation.
>> Yeah.
>> Your obligation to all of these people
wasn't to win,
>> right? Because the expected outcome is
not winning, right? The obligation was
to try hard and try smart and try
ethically. when I can break through with
the founder, you can kind of see the
relief like oh you know I did try hard
like you know like I did like and I try
to kind of convince them on the investor
side hey the investors hedged. No good
investor is making their hey on you
winning or losing right and I try to
convince them on the employee side it's
like giving the employee the freedom to
do the next thing in their career is a
gift. Yep.
>> Versus strapping them into a zombie
startup is not really a gift. So to me
when they're considering the shutdown
it's a lot about getting through these
emotions because the actual kind of
mechanisms are not that hard.
>> Yeah. Like I think again it's there's
not much content about it but one the
hard part is emotions if you can get
through them. The mechanics are easy and
you probably have a lawyer if you raise
money so you can get advice from your
lawyers. And if you have an investor
who's sophisticated and done a lot of
investments and you're just like hey we
we're going to shut down. Here's why.
They'll be like okay. and they'll give
you advice. And so I do a lot of those
office hours with founders where I kind
of walk through the mechanics. And
>> again, the key thing is to get really
clear and to put a timeline on it. And
so sometimes people have these really
amorphous ideas to get acquired, but
they have no idea how to begin and
there's no time frame on it. And that
never works. And so if someone decides
it's not working and they're a zombie
startup, it's like, okay, well give
yourself two months to try to get
acquired.
>> Yeah.
>> Put put a time frame on it. Let's go
through the mechanics of doing
introductions to potential acquirers and
talking to people. Try it. But then once
you hit that timeline, if you don't get
acquired by that date, you should just
shut down.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's totally cool. And it's almost
like a relief for them to hear that it's
not this like endless process.
>> Yeah.
>> It's actually straightforward. That
doesn't mean it's going to be a great
outcome, but the way to to get out of a
zombie startup is not that hard. I think
that speaking on acquisitions,
I think one of the challenging things
that I do when I give advice is I just
think there's an assumption that
acquisitions are far more common.
>> Y
>> and then there's
>> it's because you only hear about the
ones that worked. They're like,
"Congratulations, we failed to get
acquired,
>> right?" And so there there's a big
warping of how common these are. Then I
think the second one is the number of
acquisitions where like there are tech
crunch post, an asset sale and a job
offer. Yeah. Where suddenly it's like oh
like like you thought that when you read
about an acquisition you thought
everyone got rich. It's like that's
even less common. The other thing I talk
about a lot with acquisitions is that
it's really hard to go from no
relationship with a potential acquirer.
Yep. To an acquisition in two months.
>> Yes. So it's like there's a set of
companies maybe been interacting with or
they've been acting with you and so so
forth. Those are all great conversations
to have, but to have in your mind this
will almost be like a fundraising
process and like I'll go from like not
knowing this investor to like this
investor being on my board in three
weeks.
>> Yep.
way less common in the um acu high
world. And the last thing I talk about
is just like does your revenue matter to
an acquirer?
>> Yep. Like if you're a let's say a1 to20
million revenue company that's growing
less than 10% year-over-year and the
company that's buying you generates a
billion plus in revenue.
>> It doesn't
move their stock price. It doesn't do
any like the revenue doesn't do
anything. Like so shouldn't I be valued
at 10x my revenue? It's like ah
>> I think the real talk is like once
you're to the point of being a zombie
the odds that you will get rich from an
acquisition are effectively nil. And I
would actually frame it in a different
way which is if you're working at a
place that is not growing, you're taking
an opportunity cost on your life by
continuing to work there versus doing
something else.
>> Yes.
>> And so the actual reward is to do
something else.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Yes. and and like not an echo hire.
>> Yeah. Let me anonymize a couple of
details, but I can think of someone that
made this choice not because they were
out of money and they ended up getting a
very good job at one of the labs
>> and I'm sure they're very happy. Like
this was they they made the decision to
shut down like four years ago
>> and yeah, I think that was pretty smart.
>> I think that we are independently
thinking of people who made
>> Yeah, I'm not I'm changing some details,
but I that was a very adult decision to
make and like yeah, that was that was
the smart move. And then also we we've
been remissed to say that if you want to
start another company oftentimes those
same people if you shut down your
company responsibly and well and you
communicate clearly those same people
often want to invest in your next
company.
>> Y
>> um so we've talked about shutting down.
Let's um now address the people who
don't want to shut down. I've got this
thing going. Yep. I love it. Help me
figure out how to make it work. And I
think to start there, I kind of want to
talk about the things that won't rescue
you and just get them out of the way.
>> Yep.
>> Um, hiring a bunch more people, like
some last kind of splurge.
>> Let's burn all the money before
>> that's that's the ticket.
>> Yep.
>> The secret executive. It's really the
chief of growth or the chief of
monetization who's going to turn this
thing around. You know, they'll tell you
to send more push notifications. um spam
or other kind of low ethics way of
juicing sales like, "Hey, we have this
leaky bucket. Let's just shove as much
top of funnel as possible. Fundraising.
Well, if investors just give us
>> Yeah. we'll just pretend like we're
growing, they won't notice that we're
not growing and they'll give us money,
right?"
>> Yeah. Especially if we're pitching
something that's like on trend.
>> We have this cool AI idea.
>> They'll just give us money for that,
right? That's what investors do. So,
false escape paths. What are good escape
paths? I think that like a lot of things
in life, step one is to admit you have a
problem
>> and to be honest about it. And it's it's
surprising how often people are just in
denial where like part of their brain
knows they're a zombie startup and part
of them is like, well, you know, but but
there's like all these excuses. There's
all this cope. And so I think you just
have to like,
>> yeah,
>> get real. This isn't working. We're not
on the right trajectory. Yes. And then
what I would usually tell people is to
kind of like have like a come to Jesus
moment about how you're going to
radically change something about the
business. Yeah.
>> Because a bunch of small incremental
changes that you've been trying for the
past year or two that hasn't been
working right.
>> So you need to do something radical.
>> Yes.
>> And there is a risk that you do
something that's radically wrong. But
I'm arguing you're kind of dead anyway.
So again, this is the logic is if if
it's if none of your current efforts
have worked, you need to do something
that you would never do on your own. You
need to do something so uncomfortable.
Yes.
>> Cuz your current tactics haven't worked.
>> Yes.
>> Right. And so I'll encourage founders to
be like, what's something that seems way
too radical or scary that you've never
would have thought trying before?
This is permission. Why don't you try
it?
>> And I would say often what's the
challenge with that is sometimes these
teams are too big.
>> Yes. And you know the feedback we get
from a founders like oh well like this
person would say or what about this
department or da d or director level
yeah yada yada I'm gonna have so and
it's like
>> you have permission to maybe ask some of
those people to leave
>> because hey the ship's going down and
like they're not helping write the ship
and so often it's easier to steer a
smaller ship.
Um, I think the other thing I like to
talk about when I see founders in the
situation is like let's bring back the
pre-product market fit playbook. Like
I think very few things about a product
should be sacred when a company is
pre-product market fit. Everything
should be questioned and often times in
the zombie company they're just
assumptions about how the product should
work that like haven't been questioned
in years. You know, I was talking to a
startup the other day and they were
showing me their onboarding flow and it
was a [__] was just like a nightmare
and they had tested it. They AB tested
it was like this is the local maxima of
this bad
onboarding flow. And crazy enough they
were working on a completely different
kind of product as just like an offshoot
for a couple weeks. So they had to build
a new onboarding flow from scratch and
then they were like, "Oh, we can like
like our onboarding doesn't have to have
all this stuff. We don't have to ask 65
questions about this. Like we don't
actually have to do it this way." And
you could see them being excited because
they were like, "Oh, that means our
current onboarding flow could be like
10x better." And so to me, it's like,
can I try to find some of the sacred
cows and like unsacred cow like look at
them with fresh eyes.
>> Yeah. You almost want to get them to
name what are the sacred cows. Like
let's do a thought experiment. Let's
pretend you weren't afraid. What would
you change about your business? Let's do
the exercise.
>> Yeah.
>> And they and they people can always come
up with ones like, "Oh, I hate that, but
I can't
>> you you have all these justifications
that those are unfixable or immovable."
>> Yeah.
>> But hey, if you're already dead,
>> what what's the harm of changing some of
those things, right?
>> You know, break glass in times of
emergency.
>> Yeah. Like and I think what's what's
interesting and and often times we joke
that we see companies make the most
progress when they have low runway. I
think when you have low runway that's
like the moment where you actually
realize
>> you're like haha time to get real.
>> Yeah.
>> All those half measures, we can't do
those anymore.
>> And like I feel like if I could bottle
that up and give that feeling to the
companies in the zombie mode who like
you know often times they have years of
runway. Well, that's the irony is
overfunding
causes zombies
like all the the unicorn stuff where
there's,
>> you know, it's way more likely to end up
with a zombie.
>> Yes.
>> When you've raised way more than you
thought you needed.
>> Yes. Right.
>> Yes.
>> Last one on this point about conviction.
I see a lot of founders in this position
who are like, I don't know what to do
and so the solution is to hedge across
five different things, right?
And
what do you say to the founder who's
like, "Okay, you know, I acknowledge I'm
in zombie mode. I'm going to make a good
plan. Like, we're going to figure this
out." But like, Dalton, rationally, we
don't know which one of these to do.
Like, I can't like, you know, shouldn't
we be trying a bunch of stuff? At the
end of the day, the real job of a
founder is to
point the way forward and to believe
harder than everybody else. You mean
it's not to sit back and send scouts out
and
But it but it's true cuz like imagine
working for someone and the person
you're working for doesn't seem like
they have a clue, right? Imagine you're
an investor in someone and the people
you're investing in doesn't seem to have
a clue. Yeah.
>> And they have no vision.
>> Yeah.
>> And so if you truly have no idea what to
do, it's very hard. Like I don't know
how to advise you.
>> Yeah. But I have seen people that have
strong conviction in a wrong motivate
the people around them and then
recalibrate. Yeah.
>> Like like keep changing the thing that
they're strong conviction about. That
totally works.
>> That counterintuitively works, right?
Starting in the wrong direction,
>> but like being really hardcore about it.
You can get people to follow you and you
could like make stuff happen if you're
wrong, but if you're just completely
>> lost.
>> Yeah. It's funny because when I find
founders in that situation, often times
what I try to communicate to them is
they're like, "You know so much more
about the user than you did when you
started. You know so much more about the
industry than you do. Like you have so
many more raw materials to have
conviction about something now than you
did when we funded you at YC." And like
it's almost like,
yeah, your startup might not be working,
but you are 10x smarter about this. And
like if we were to flip this, right, and
you were an investor, you'd be able to
look at other companies in this space
and you'd have some opinions about like
what users want and what's big and
what's not. I try to give the founder
confidence like that work that they did
was useful. Like even though that work
they've done so far might not have
produced a billion dollar company, it
was useful. And their ideas are weirdly
more likely to work.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz they know something.
>> Yeah. They know something.
It's like
>> it's way more likely.
>> It's way more likely.
>> Well, and that's why often if they're
like, I don't see it. I don't believe in
the space at all. I believe them.
>> Like, you just worked on this for 2
years and you're telling me there's
nothing here.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm not I have no argument.
>> Yes. Yes. And so, I think that's like
the cool thing is that if you give
yourself permission to take the big
swing, it's counterintuitively more
likely that swing will work because you
know what you're doing now.
>> Yep.
>> And man, like knowing what you're doing
is pretty helpful.
I'd recommend it.
>> Yeah, all things being equal.
>> Anyways, great chat, Dan.
>> All right, thanks, Michael.